someone is going around VCT lock-in and
stealing earbuds yep earbuds but
valorent Pros aren't the only ones who
got robbed this past weekend so who's
taking all this equipment
[Music]
before we get into the video I just want
to remind you guys that we have some
nice and comfy merch like this crew neck
that I'm wearing right now head to
shop.thescore.com to check it out so as
many of you already know VCT lock-in is
on right now 32 teams from around the
world traveled to Brazil to compete in
valerian's biggest ever event and so far
it's been hype we saw new rosters take
the stage for the first time and the
alpha side of the bracket was incredible
very far away from being back online to
see because why give it to him it is
going to be the res instead but he's
gonna go swinging
the second attempt in it now has to be
dealt with oh
incredible walk of Dr Rick's a removable
at this point and they've got the word
cut out to say the least Infamous the
timing ain't there
oh my goodness
[Applause]
and souls into this game I've had a lot
of fun watching lock-ins so far even if
I do think that the format is but
as enjoyable as it's been for the
viewers there's something going on
behind the scenes and it kind of sucks
for some of the players a week ago Genji
player King tweeted that someone had
stolen his in-ear headphones someone
replied asking whether or not there are
security cameras in the practice rooms
to which king replied no King spoke with
Brazilian Outlet the enemy and mentioned
that Riot likely won't be able to find
his in-ears and that he'd have to buy
another pair for roughly 200 US dollars
now obviously this sucks and it leaves
us wondering why there are no cameras or
security monitoring these practice rooms
but since King's initial tweet last week
things have gotten worse on February
16th King tweeted that his teammate's
secrets in ears had all also been stolen
and on the 19th rrq player to bodle
tweeted that both his in-ears and his
sound card were taken I asked to bodle
about the situation in yesterday's press
conference and he said that he managed
to get his sound card back but not his
in-ears so for now he's just practicing
with a normal headset Liz also spoke
with Asana and cryo about the situation
and they shared some advice for other
players at the event so what's your
strap to avoid the headphones
Thief pick my stuff up and bring him
with me yeah the very good solution is
just bring your stuff with you yeah
we've been doing that since day one
before we even knew there was a
quote-unquote so I mean I wouldn't
really trust anyone we still don't know
who's going around and stealing these
peripherals and who knows if we'll ever
find out but the crazy thing is that
this isn't the only Esports robbery that
happened this past weekend on the 18th
tsm's League of Legends support chime
and the team's top laner solo both
tweeted that their team car was broken
into and their backpacks were stolen one
of the team's video editors also
mentioned on the TSM subreddit that
their Lunar New Year footage featuring
members of the team and fans was also
lost unlike the headphone thief in Sao
Paulo this robber in La stole some
things that both players and staff
considered to be invaluable so it's
understandable that they were literally
begging for them to be returned and
thankfully later that night solo tweeted
an update that someone found their
backpacks in a nearby parking lot and
they managed to get some of their
personal belongings back luckily the
situation with TS sm's League team had a
somewhat happy ending but over in Brazil
the question Still Remains who is this
headphone thief and what will Riot do to
stop them fans attending the event have
already criticized Riot for poor
conditions at the venue this post from a
few days ago on the valorent competitive
subreddit outlined a bunch of problems
some of the big ones were lack of air
conditioning very expensive water no
meet and greets with any of the players
and the fact that you can pretty much
only walk in with the clothes on your
back plenty of people have also pointed
out that there are a bunch of empty
seats whenever non-brazilian teams are
playing thankfully Riot did listen to
some of this criticism the global head
of valorent Esports Leo Faria tweeted on
Sunday that they will start selling more
seats for non-brazilian matches and
they're getting rid of the reloadable
card that fans use to buy food and
drinks alongside some other changes I
think it's great that Riot is listening
to the community and helping Their
audience feel more comfortable at the
venue the Brazilian fans have been
incredible so far but I'm still
concerned for the players there's been
no update from Riot regarding this
headphone thief and it feels like it's
only a matter of time before they find a
new Target
ah
single elimination with 32 teams like
come on like the winning team earns the
earns their region extra slot at Masters
Tokyo I think like if Riot is gonna go
ahead and say oh it's just like this
event that's meant to Showcase all the
new teams like it's supposed to be fun
yeah it's been fun but you can't have
any sort of stakes in a single limb
tournament like I don't think it makes
any sense personally but I could go on
about this forever